the last few months I've been looking
out the window of my office you can see
it just behind me and watching a new
building being built with lecture
theatres for the students and a few days
ago walking to lunch I thought this is a
fantastic opportunity to talk about the
chemistry of concrete so here we are on
the top of the building site in a
hardhat special gloves periodic tie and
we're ready to go with chemistry of
concrete and as I speak the lorry is
arriving with the concrete ready to be
poured and we'll watch it coming out so
now they're pouring the concrete out
into this skin and they're going to
brain it up to where we can see being
pulled out so this is what I've been
watching out of my window you can see
the concrete skit going up now on this
big frame and it'll go high over our
heads to where they're going to pull the
chemistry of concrete is quite simple
somewhere you dig up limestone calcium
carbonate and then you heat it up and
drive off the carbon dioxide to make
calcium oxide some people call it lime
and then you mix this with sand sand is
silicon dioxide sio2 silicon is in the
same group as carbon in the periodic
table so you take the mixture of sand
and lime and you add to this some sort
of stone is known as aggregate what
they're pouring here is 25% aggregates
it's recycled aggregates they haven't
done the stone out from under the ground
they've used recycled stone because my
university is very conscious of being
green we have one of the greenest
campuses in the UK
when you make these together the
aggregates the silicon dioxide and the
lime and you mix them with water then
the chemical reaction starts and as long
as you keep it moving nothing set solid
but as soon as you let it stand the
silicon dioxide and the calcium oxide
react together and make a sort of jelly
which gets harder and harder take
several days to get really hard and then
it reacts with a carbon dioxide in the
air for years and years and years
afterwards so Roman concrete that was
made 2,000 years ago is really hard
because it's had 2,000 years to react
with the carbon dioxide in the air but
this is something that was made
yesterday and you can see the aggregate
here these lumps sticking out and it's
already very hard I can't break it and
the important thing about concrete is
it's very strong in compression if you
press it you can heart you can put an
enormous load before it breaks it's not
nearly so strong in tension if you pull
it I'm not strong enough but if you pull
this it would break fairly easily
compared to what would happen if you
compressed it and to make it even
stronger people put in steel mesh you
can see some here the reinforcement rods
which the concrete can bind to the steel
and this gives it added strength as far
as I know nobody's ever going to run out
of concrete The Cliffs of Dover the
White Cliffs of Dover the symbol of
Britain are entirely made out of calcium
carbonate there is possibly problems
with the carbon dioxide you generate
which add to global warming but we're
never going to run out of concrete
concrete is much weaker if you have
bubbles in them so that when you pour
the concrete it's been vibrated to make
sure that all the bubbles float to the
surface
if you do get bubbles it breaks easily
the chemical company i seei about 30
years ago made a special sort of cement
which you could get up all the bubbles
and you can make Springs and all sorts
of strange things out of concrete or
cement that normally you can't use they
even made bottle tops for drinks bottles
out of cement the main difference
between cement and concrete is whether
you add the aggregate whether you add
this extra stones and the people who
pour cement can make different mixtures
for different purposes they make special
mixtures to use underwater because
concrete will set even when it's
underwater for example if you're
building a dam or if you're building
some sort of bridge where it's on very
wet soil perhaps not completely
underwater but in very saturated soil it
is very cheap it's very strong and you
can use it in all sorts of different
applications you can tune it and you can
also do it very quickly this beam that's
being poured over here will be ready
tomorrow I had a colleague who died 10
years ago
Martin marker who was interested in the
chemistry of liquid sodium and he did
some experiments with liquid sodium
reacting with concrete this is the
ultimate nuclear reactor disaster when
the core melts and sodium coolant goes
into the concrete and he found that
there was quite a violent reaction
depending on the aggregate but there was
some very interesting chemistry and I
persuaded him to give a lecture that he
called some
feat results from sodium chemistry and
it was a very successful venture well it
just feels like it's some stones but you
can see here are the pieces of aggregate
and the concrete itself the cement sand
mixture is pretty wet now and over the
next two hours this will say it's solid
the foreman here said they didn't be
hard enough to remove the shuttering and
eight hours they'd be dark by then so
they'll leave it till tomorrow morning